I have tried to be fair by following two  broad principles firstly we ask those  with more to contribute more and  secondly we avoid the tax Rises that  damage growth although my decisions  today do lead to a substantial tax  increase we have not raised headline  rates of Taxation and tax as a  percentage of GDP will increase by just  one percent over the next five years  I start with personal taxes  asking more from those who have more  means that the first difficult decision  I take on tax is to reduce the Threshold  at which the 45p rate becomes payable  from 150 000 pounds to 125  140 pounds those earning 150 000 pounds  or more will pay just over 1200 pounds  more in tax every year